>> Sean: JOINING US NOW IS THE
ATTORNEY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
DAVID SCHOEN FOR THIS
IMPEACHMENT I CALLED THE SCHIFF
SHOW CHARADE.
WE’VE BEEN FRIENDS A LONG TIME,
DAVID.
I LOVED YOUR ARGUMENTS AND YOUR
PASSION.
I THINK IT STARTED A LITTLE
MEANDERING, A LOT OF FREE
ASSOCIATING IN THE BEGINNING AND
I’M NOT ATTACKING YOUR PARTNER,
I DON’T KNOW HIM AT ALL, BUT I
LIKED FOCUSED ARGUMENTS AND I
PARTICULARLY LIKED YOU ACTUALLY
RAN TAPE OF THE DEMOCRATS
POINTING OUT THE OBVIOUS THAT
THE NEWS HAS CHANGED QUITE A BIT
SINCE THIS SNAP IMPEACHMENT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY, VERY
PAINFUL AND WRONG PROCESS FOR
THE COUNTRY.
AS YOU SAID EARLIER IN YOUR
SHOW, IT’S VERY EASY TO STAND UP
AND SHOW SPLICED AND
MANUFACTURED FILMS, THE
DEMOCRATS, THE HOUSE MANAGERS
HIRED A LARGE MOVIE COMPANY IN A
LARGE LAW FIRM TO PUT TOGETHER
THIS THING.
IT’S A MATTER OF TRICKING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO PLAY AS IF
THE WRITING WAS GOING ON IN REAL
TIME WITH THE SPEECH, WHAT’S THE
PURPOSE OF THAT?
WHY DO WE WANT TO TRICK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IT HAS GREAT
ENTERTAINMENT VALUE, PEOPLE ARE
GLUED TO MOVIES MADE
PROFESSIONALLY LIKE THAT.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO ADVANCE ANY
CAUSE OF GOOD AND THE COUNTRY.
>> Sean: THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ISSUE OF JURISDICTION, LET’S GO
OVER THAT AND WHY THIS IS NOT
CONSTITUTIONAL.
>> SO MANY REASONS WHY IT’S NOT
IT’S FUNNY, THE HOUSE MANAGERS
SAID SUCH A CLEAR QUESTION,
SAYING IT’S A CLOSE CALL IT BEST
BUT COMMON SENSE, NOBODY THINKS
OF USING THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS
FOR ANYTHING OTHER THEN REMOVING
A CIVIL OFFICIAL FROM OFFICE.
WE HAVE COURTS.
IF YOU WANT TO HAVE AN
INVESTIGATION OF A WANT TO
PROSECUTE SOMEONE, WE HAVE
COURTS FOR THAT.
THAT’S NOT WHAT IMPEACHMENT IS
FOR WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE CONSTITUTION
TODAY, THAT SORT OF THING.
IT’S ABSOLUTELY NONSENSE FOR THE
PRESIDENT IS NO LONGER THE
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW AND IS A
PERSON WHO CAN’T BE REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
HE IS A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
THIS IS WHAT OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS ARE VERY MUCH AGAINST,
HAVING A LEGISLATIVE BODY TRY A
PRIVATE CITIZEN.
THINK ABOUT IT, HE DOESN’T GET
ANY THE BENEFITS ARE SAFEGUARDS
THAT OUR CONSTITUTION PROVIDES
FOR SOMEONE WHO HAS AN ACTUAL
TRIAL.
THAT VIDEOTAPE WOULD NEVER GO
INTO EVIDENCE ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD TODAY.
IT’S A SPICE TAPE SHOWING WHAT
THEY WANT TO SHOW.
>> Sean: IT’S PRETTY PROFOUND
TO ME THAT THE MEDIA IS NOW
ACKNOWLEDGING WE HAVE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE FBI
ACKNOWLEDGING, WE HAVE COURT
DOCUMENTS ACKNOWLEDGING,
OCASIO-CORTEZ THE CONGRESSWOMAN
ACKNOWLEDGING, ALL THESE PEOPLE
NOW DISCUSSING HOW INEFFECTIVE
THIS IS ALL PREPLANNED.
HOW DO YOU MAKE THE ARGUMENT
THAT AT A RALLY, THE WORDS OF
THE PRESIDENT TO PEACEFULLY AND
PATRIOTICALLY MARCH TO THE
CAPITAL’S ARE YOUR VOICES ARE
HEARD, HOW DO YOU MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT THAT INCITED AND
INSURRECTION WHEN IN FACT IT WAS
ALL PLANNED OUT APPARENTLY AHEAD
OF TIME ACCORDING TO ALL OF
THESE VARIOUS SOURCES NOW?
>> EVEN TAKING THE POSITION THAT
THAT SPEECH INCITED AND
INSURRECTION IS AS DANGEROUS AS
I CAN IMAGINE THE FREE SPEECH
AREA WHICH SHOULD ABSOLUTELY
CHILL PASSIONATE POLITICAL
SPEECH.
TRUMP JR. SAID IT BEST, THAT
COMPARED TO OTHER RHETORIC YOU
HEAR, IF YOU READ THE SPEECH AND
LOGIC, WHEN HE USES THE WORD
FIGHT, IT’S IN THE CONTEXT OF A
LEGISLATOR FIGHTING OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
IT’S REALLY SETTING A HORRIBLE
MESSAGE TO PEOPLE.
I UNDERSTAND THEY DON’T LIKE
DONALD TRUMP ON THAT SIDE OF THE
AISLE.
HALF THE COUNTRY LOVES HIM.
I WOULD SAY IF HE HAD
7,475,000,000 VOTERS, THEY VOTED
FOR HIM BECAUSE THEY LOVE
DONALD TRUMP.
I DON’T KNOW THAT MANY OTHER
CANDIDATES COULD SAY THAT.
PEOPLE MAY HAVE VOTED BECAUSE
THEY DIDN’T WANT DONALD TRUMP,
THE OTHER AND HE’S A PASSIONATE
PERSON AND IS SETTING A VERY
DANGEROUS AND IT’S A HOAX, I’M
SORRY TO SAY.
>> Sean: THE STANDARDS FOR HOW
THEY DEFINE INCITEMENT AND
INSURRECTION, WHAT IF WE APPLIED
IT AS WE STARTED OUR MONOLOGUE
TONIGHT TO THE WORDS OF
JOE BIDEN, KAMALA HARRIS,
CHUCK SCHUMER, NANCY PELOSI,
MAXINE WATERS, AND A WHOLE HOST
OF OTHERS.
IF THAT SAME STANDARD IS
APPLIED, DO THEY NOT ALL DESERVE
IMPEACHMENT >> Greg: BY THE
WAY, I DON’T AGREE WITH IT, BUT
YOU USE THEIR STANDARD, IT SEEMS
SOMEWHAT INTELLECTUALLY HONEST,
YOU’D HAVE TO SAY THEY DESERVE
IMPEACHMENT.
>> IF THEY TRIED TO IMPEACH
THEM, I WOULD SAY WAS AN ABUSE
OF THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS BUT
THEY ARE USING RHETORIC THAT IS
JUST AS INFLAMMATORY OR MORE SO.
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY DON’T HAVE
FOLLOWERS, DEDICATED FOLLOWERS
WHEN THEY GIVE SPEECHES, SO THIS
SPEECH RIGHT NOW YOU ARE FINDING
OUT ABOUT THE PREPLANNING AND
I’M AFRAID THEY’RE GOING TO BACK
OFF THAT INVESTIGATION BECAUSE
SO MANY PEOPLE WANT TO TIE IT TO
DONALD TRUMP.
THERE’S NOTHING THEY SHOWED
TODAY THAT IN ANY WAY TIES IT TO
DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS NOT TIED TO DONALD TRUMP
OR HIS SPEECH WHATSOEVER SO WHAT
THEY’RE DOING NOW IS SAYING YOU
SEE, IT’S NOT JUST HIS SPEECH,
HE’S BEEN INCITING PEOPLE AND
INFLAMING PEOPLE.
HE’S BEEN AROUSING THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC TO DRAIN THE SWAMP,
WHATEVER THEY CALL IT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHAT POLITICAL SPEECH IS
ABOUT.
>> Sean: THERE’S A LOT OF
CRITICISM OF THE OPENING, NOT
YOUR PART IN PARTICULAR, BUT IT
SEEMED TO BE FREE ASSOCIATING,
EXTEMPORANEOUS, SOMEWHAT
MEANDERING.
WILL THE REST OF THIS PROCESS
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO BE OUT
AS I UNDERSTAND IT FRIDAY
INSIDER DAY, WILL THIS BE MORE
FOCUSED AND MORE PREPARED, ARE
THERE OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
PLANNING TO MAKE THOSE ARGUMENTS
BECAUSE SOME CONSERVATIVES
CALLED ME AND SAID WE NEED
SOMEBODY HARDER HITTING HERE.
>> THE FELLOW WHO DID THE
OPENING TODAY IS THE LAW FIRM,
VERY CAPABLE PEOPLE.
TODAY HE HADN’T PLANNED ON
GOING, SO I’M SURE THEY WILL BE
VERY WELL PREPARED IN THE FUTURE
AND DO A GREAT JOB IN THE CASE.
THERE’S A LOT TO SAY AND I KNOW
YOU FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT